no let up at all in the fighting in
ukraine and the propaganda war is also
intensifying
a clinic comes under attack who's to
blame
residential areas flattened the same
question who is to blame the whole city
cut off again who's to blame
it's a battle of words between a man
whose country clearly stands behind him
and an autocrat with a long record of
pulverizing opposition
on to the point we are selensky against
putin
whose truth is stronger
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you very much for joining us
today and my guests here in the studio
are natalia smolenzeva
a russian-born journalist now with
deutsche weller here in germany
also with us is suitor david wilke from
the german marshall fund and a warm
welcome to tomorrow's scat man chief
reporter with the german magazine cicero
thank you all three for being with us
here today and
on this show today we wanted to look at
the power of words and the power of
images
and where better to begin them with
natalya i'd like to ask you natalia to
decipher for us
some video that a lot of people have
been seeing that has had a lot of
influence give us your take on what it's
all about here we go
so we see this as a live broadcast on
monday night on one of the main russian
state channels and for a couple of
seconds
editor marina sanikova rushed into the
studio behind the presenter holding a
sign saying
basically no to war and saying
don't believe in propaganda they are
lying to you
this is
this was just a short moment it was cut
then in the live tv but it spread
immediately on social huge impact
exactly it was discussed both in russia
and outside of russia
we have to know that some social media
is already restricted in russia so i
guess not a lot of people have seen it
or not everyone has seen it but among
those who have seen it it was uh you
know debated whether it was real or fake
and whether it's a heroic act or is it
just
the way for her what's your take on it
was it real was it fake it was real and
now we know because we know this person
and she's been already um
she had a court hearing already she was
already given you know a fine for this
action so we do know it's real and
we do know that
why she did it she also released the
video saying that um
her personal story this is very
important for her her father is ukraine
and her mother in russian despite the
fact that she's been working for
russian state tv russian propaganda
essentially for past years this is the
red line she couldn't cross basically
it's really powerful stuff yeah
uh moritz could you tell us we're going
to bring up now and uh a photo image
which i'd like to ask you to uh tell
tell us what it signifies for you yeah
well this is a photo from the city
mariupol which is like half a million
in ukraine and it's a besieged
city and what we see is the impact of a
russian rocket attack
on a hospital
in mariupol several days ago and we see
a pregnant woman who was carried away
even though the photographer it's
a ukrainian photographer who is in the
city until now
and of course this is a very very
emotional picture and it of course it
doesn't fit totally doesn't fit with the
the idea that russia is trying to uh to
give of this war russia is saying it's a
special operation
uh against the ukrainian military
against some nazis
and of course in the moment when when
they attack hospitals in ukraine
and this leads to to
this impact
uh it's it's horrifying and uh
absolutely yeah okay well to reiterate
what we've seen we've seen the images of
that dreadful attack on the maternity
hospital a pregnant woman and her baby
died when the hospital
where she was meant to give birth was
attacked i'd like to ask you
david wilt what are your thoughts about
those two series of images
well there are two images that have
certainly struck a chord um both in
terms of the bravery of this woman that
um stood up in the face of great danger
but spoke her mind because many russians
who don't agree with putin's actions are
leaving the country so the ones that are
staying behind are certainly under risk
for speaking out and as you mentioned
she went through two days of you know
lack of sleep and probably fear for her
life and is now out but who knows what
you know will happen to her next
and the other image also of course
strikes
fears for the civilian population in
ukraine because this of course brings
about questions about
is our you know is this regime in russia
committing war crimes because there is a
deliberate attack on civilian
infrastructure
and on hospitals and um w.h.o has
actually already spoken out against it
well natalia what would you say about
this about these discussions now about
war crimes and genocide i mean you you
grew up in russia that's where you spent
most of your life tell us how you
reflect on that what you're seeing now
well for me as russian it's really hard
to see what
russia my country essentially is doing
in ukraine um i've been in russia just
recently just um two weeks ago and this
moment when the war started was you know
i guess one of the worst moments i've
experienced honestly because until the
last moment i couldn't believe this was
possible even when the um and i think
many people i read this that you had
said this you couldn't believe it i mean
for me as a little bit of an outsider
we'd seen this symbolic uh gesture this
huge dramatic theatrical gesture of the
convoy moving forward so threateningly
we've seen this as well and a lot of
people i've been talking in in moscow
like during my reports and just on the
daily live they said no it's all staged
it's all the game putin is playing he
wants to you know get something else
from the west he wants to get an
agreement he wants to be recognized as
the superpower but he will never ever
wage a war against ukraine this is just
insane
and you know we all woke up on the
morning of 24th and
understood that it is insane the world
had changed the world completely has
changed
i mean one thing that i want to add i
arrived in ukraine and the eastern part
of ukraine the day before the war
started and even there people didn't
want to believe that
this kind of war would start that a
large-scale
war against the whole country would
start people thought that maybe there
would be some escalation at the front
line or anything but but they couldn't
believe that this would happen even like
right next to this to these peoples
republics
where people knew what war was like they
didn't want to believe one thing i
wanted to add concerning these pictures
you know i've lived
five years in russia i have relatives
there i have friends there and what's
really
hard for me to understand
how russians i mean these pictures they
also arrive in russia what's what's
happening there
and
i mean the the whole the houses the
people
the faces the way people talk
they are it's very similar to russian
cities
these places
how they look like all these houses from
soviet times they could be in
vladivostok in moscow in saint
petersburg anywhere and i can't
understand how
uh russians
can
can can accept and can somehow realize
that this is happening that
people and places who are very similar
to them
and they get bombed by their army at the
moment
what's your answer to that question
because i think you know we're all
thinking about it sure it's very
interesting that you bring that up
because this picture of um
the woman being carted out of the
hospital the pregnant woman you know
russia has said that this is a crisis
actor and if you look to for example the
united states you hear fringe voices on
the right also talking about you know
gun
violence school shootings like what
happened in connecticut to the
kindergarten sandy hook as being you
know those were all crisis actors so
somehow people are being you know
brainwashed with disinformation
about what the actual state is as you
mentioned before uh putin has prepared
the russian people to think that this is
a war a glorious war
of you know freeing the ukrainians from
nazis right so he's tried to hearken
back to a time of russian patriotism
namely world war ii okay before we move
on because it's very interesting let's
just listen to how vladimir putin
himself explains why he began this awful
war
and
he gave this speech in an address to
ukrainian soldiers that's important to
mention
dear comrades
your grandfathers and great grandfathers
did not fight the nazis and defend our
common fatherland so that neo-nazis
could seize power in ukraine
you made an oath to serve the ukrainian
people
they are a fascist who have seized power
they are plundering ukraine
and exploiting its people
don't fulfill their criminal orders lay
down your weapons and go home
okay so we want to talk a little bit
about language today and i think it's
very important or very interesting there
uh
moritz that uh
we there's vladimir putin who has said
you have been talking about the fact
that there is a war being fought that
there is devastation and destruction
vladimir putin is telling his people
that they may not use the word war to
describe what is going on how shocking
is that what does that tell us
well actually to be honest uh no nation
that's
who's starting a war is talking about
war actually i mean we know it from
germany we know it from other countries
people liked it politicians who started
war they like to to talk about
special operations
about operations limited operations
whatever they they're not saying we are
going to war we are waging a war
war is unpopular
everywhere and so putin is trying to
copy
western leaders maybe
but
the
i think
the problem is that
nobody is buying this in the country
he's attacking
he's
talking to the ukrainian soldiers and to
the ukrainian people
and telling them that russia comes to
liberate
the country from a nazi junta i just
want to add that zelensky is a jew
you know the president of the country is
an important point yeah it's an
important point and maybe there are lots
of ukrainians who were
dissatisfied with the president before
this war started
there are several points of critique of
course it's no perfect country it's no
perfect democracy but it's definitely no
junta and people in ukraine they didn't
want to be
liberated
and that's why maybe the only people who
are believing this are some alt-right
people in the in the u.s and
some russians who believe in the state
propaganda but
in ukraine this didn't work not at all
exactly i think the question is whether
this is actually addressed to the
ukrainian population and putin is just
so like russian um leadership is so full
that ukraine is is waiting for
for russian army to being liberated or
whether this is actually addressed to
the russian population to reinforce this
narrative that you know what we are
doing is not they're actually saying
this what we are doing is not the war is
the prevention of the war which is like
calling black white and white black so
to say so in this this
that was the point i mean i mean
you're saying it's standard practice for
a country going to war but for i i feel
as though it is a
total abuse of language
orwellian abusive language that you say
that one thing is another thing you turn
it on its head you make a mockery of
language
but but i think that uh putin
believed in what he was saying
i think putin and maybe the people
around him they believe that still in
ukraine
a russian-speaking person means
a pro-russian person you know
in odessa odessa is a russian-speaking
city kharkiv which is under attack now
as a russian-speaking city
and he thought that
the fact that they speak russian means
that they are pro-russian and when the
russians attack they would come out uh
with russian flags and would greet the
liberators
but it
totally
didn't work out i just checked the the
other day there are some pro-russian
politicians in kharkiv for example the
former governor who was always very
pro-russian and
anti-revolution in 2014 you know but
but he's defending the city now
against the russian occupiers how they
are called in ukraine at the moment so
yeah so i think i have a feeling they've
obviously miscalculated this and
i mean i don't know personally why but
there is this feeling that you know
maybe also because of the pandemic that
putin has been
um you know quite an isolation and this
political elite has been in isolation
and it seems like they've um the
propaganda they've created all the
narrative they've created for their own
public at some point they started
believing their own
the distance from the real world that
absurd table for example that we've seen
time and again exactly this gap from
what exactly is happening in ukraine or
elsewhere in the world and how this is
portrayed in the head so
i don't know when was the calculation
back there but it doesn't seem that the
calculation was to hold this war for
such a long time it was obviously this
bliss creek and and fast operation and
hope that they will be probably greeted
with flowers as it's portrayed in
russian tv so maybe this was the idea in
the very putin's head that didn't really
match the reality
so um we have a uh
group in our organization called the
alliance for securing democracy and we
monitor russian disinformation and some
of the narratives that are being put out
right now are about
ukraine having chemical and biological
weapons
you know resuscitating its nuclear
program being a vassal state of the
united states right so these are things
that are out there but in a way it sort
of foreshadows what russia perhaps
intends to do right what the and in that
way justifies perhaps future actions of
russia so i think it's yes propaganda
for its people but also in a way um you
know sort of projecting in the mirror
what russia intends to do in ukraine as
well it has to be said in all fairness
that the the us has a track record as
well um
colin powell
you know i think that that was a war um
that
it was it was not a
war that
the united states provoked
sure there was faulty intelligence
but um there was um
it wasn't a war of choice perhaps you
know i mean to say what blinken said
because i i mean i think that there is a
clear difference um
it was a different time this is an
unprovoked unjustified act of aggression
on the part of
russia but i want to add as a german who
has lots to do with russians
who was discussing with russians over
the last 20 years
i'm thinking about the iraq war all the
time over the last
days
i was
demonstrating against the iraq war in
germany at that moment but still we
couldn't prevent it
and i would say that the harm this war
did
we also see it today because
russia is using
something like the iraq war
as a justification to uh its own people
because
russia says template the americans are
also doing this we can do it too and i i
at this moment i can't really uh
answer no it's not true i mean i think
there's a clear difference between um
the united states and russia in terms of
you know
the united states
has caused harm with the iraq war no
doubt about it but it still sees itself
as a benign power it still believes in
the rule of law it believes in
democratic values i don't think you can
compare the united states with russia
and the what about ism that putin is
trying to put out there is exactly what
we need to stand to get up against in
order to have resolve in the west
against putin's actions in ukraine but
the iraq war still um made the
make the position of the west or the
moral position of especially the us uh
much weaker
i think i think you can all
point to i mean we're changing the topic
of this program but i think you could
point to the united states in several
occasions over history but the point is
that the united states also has a track
record of correcting itself and being a
benign power for the liberal
international order that's my belief
let's get back to ukraine it's very
important we do so the the conflict has
uh promoted has prompted ukrainian uh
president vladimir salinsky to
uh
turn on his to his people uh
on what seems like a sort of a daily
basis you'd almost have to say and it's
very dramatic what he has to say and
it's often very strong stuff let's
listen in
today we must be united in condemning
this war crime of russia which reflects
all the evil that the occupiers have
brought to our land
all of the destroyed cities and
everything they've done
the bombing of a maternity hospital is
conclusive evidence that what is
happening is a genocide of ukrainians
[Music]
natalie what do you say to that that
accusation of genocide that's the a very
very very downer crime yeah
the genocide is used in this speech
which is also used in the russian
propaganda actually
so
it's it's a very very serious accusation
and i cannot always speak for the
russian government or even for the
russian people there for me it's it's
really painful to see what's happening
there and
as a russian i feel horrible every day
talking to my friends talking to my
friends in ukraine about it but if we um
see right now this is also on the
informational
part this this um
war between these narratives as you
mentioned the very beginning and we also
have to um have to see what the russian
side has to say well the ukrainian side
has to say on this in the senate that
they're trying to build this narrative
and of course the ukrainian narrative is
supported or what the
president is saying is supported by the
west and it
seems to be that it's the the truth
narrative there but then in order to win
i think we need to find a way how to
fight the
propaganda and misinformation that's
happening in russia this is very crucial
and that's very crucial to be a lies of
these people who stand up to this as
well russia could end up very very very
isolated indeed
at the end of this whole uh
this war
that it could be it could take almost a
lifetime to recover to get back to where
people were how how disturbing is that
for you
it is very disturbing and the past week
i've been at home um i've been in moscow
that time
i've seen people just
sitting looking at this not believing in
huge shock of what's happening
and no matter where they stand in this
position that most of people i know
they're against this and they they in
shock what's happening and they don't
support this they're just seeing their
lives being
thrown out of the window they've seen
all their
you know projects all their savings
everything just get out and it's beyond
all belief it's just not where what we
expected obviously and the sanctions
will hit really hard especially these
people
people who are open-minded who are you
know in their 30s 40s who've managed to
do something with their lives and now
one day to another they
just don't have it all and of course we
can talk about that they're also to
blame and
people in russia are probably also
responsible to to large extent what's
happening there
but
does it help
does it help us to fight putin
i would add that the crazy thing is that
one of
putin's main points of his uh why people
still voted for him after 20 years was
the
word stability you know yeah that i mean
he said okay the 90s were a time of
chaos of uh poverty and
we rebuilt this country and i guarantee
stability
and now he's throwing all the stability
out of the window
to wage this war against ukraine and
this brings me to the point that to
think that uh putin has somehow lost
uh
the the last contact with with reality
he's thinking
in categories of being a historic person
of being some kind of napoleon
with a historic mission
and he doesn't care about things like
economy anymore
important points very very very
important by suitor i just like to come
back to you because we sort of ganged up
on you just a little bit just now uh as
as
being an american i just want to uh
the americans are obviously a key player
in what's going on in the in central
europe at this point in time it's a long
way away but it isn't for americans can
you explain how people are sort of
reading the situation for us well i
think for one thing um the ukrainian
people have won the hearts and minds of
the united states
uh zielinski
will be speaking to a joint session of
the us congress and i think that um it's
made the people in the united states
realize that freedom and democracy are
not um to be taken for granted so i
think that has definitely waken people
woken people up about um the fragility
of democracy
and of course when you think about the
region it also shows that the united
states still plays a major role in
keeping the stability
of europe and i think if it were up to
countries in central and eastern europe
they certainly want a strong united
states present and this whole idea of
europe taking its security into its own
hands or this concept of strategic
autonomy is um certainly
on the back burner for now okay maurice
we're running out of time just a little
bit but i did want to come back to you
because there was uh you wrote an item
about uh what you experienced when you
were still recently in ukraine and you
you you were quite explicit in it and
just a little bit sort of unjournalistic
in that you said it broke your heart
that's that's how it felt to me tell me
a little bit more about how it broke
your heart
it actually broke my heart because
uh i'm not only writing about this
eastern european region about russia
ukraine armenia and all these countries
over the last 20 years i have many
friends there i have relatives there and
i somehow saw my mission in
explaining russia to the germans
explaining germans to the russians
uh and building bridges actually and my
belief is that
i mean
there are a lot of setbacks you know
like putin's getting more authoritarian
everything and all his his campaigns
against gay people and so on but still i
was i believed in
that we were going
in the right direction
and of course this moment when
when when russia
and the russian army
attacks ukraine where i also have many
friends
it destroys everything
and i think it will take a very long
time to
let me pick up on that because one one
of my colleagues said that he could
imagine he said it's a quirky position
perhaps have at this point in time but
we could be out of this in a couple of
weeks time is that in any way likely
or is this a dig
a deep wall we really don't know i think
from what i hear from the you know
people um assessing the military of the
separations cannot drag for more than a
couple of weeks but then again nobody
expected this to start in the first
place so at this point i think we can't
really
okay
we've got to leave it there i'm afraid
thanks very much for joining us if
you've er i hope we've given you at
least food for thought for now goodbye
and just
[Music]
[Music]
you